une agglomération au ralenti excepté
dans certains commerces comme dans le
reste de la france
l'ensemble des supermarchés hypermarchés
commerce de détail reste ouvert à saint
quentin en yvelines pour y faire ses
courses il vous faudra tout de même vous
armer de patience une solution peut-être
vous rendre dans les boucheries
fromageries et autres commerces de
détail ou encore à la ferme de grignon
la boutique gourmande restent ouvertes à
la vente directe rester ouverts aussi
dans l'agglomération les pharmacies les
garages stations service les magasins
spécialisés dans l'informatique tabac
hôtels mais aussi plus étonnant
peut-être les papeteries blanchisserie
et laveries du côté des services de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le réseau stibus est maintenue
bien que réduit sur les lignes
desservant les établissements scolaires
même chose pour les trains depuis les
gares de l'agglomération avec une
réduction pour l'instant légère du
trafic
tous les autres équipements publics
piscine médiathèque et lieux
touristiques sont quant à eux fermés
depuis vendredi l'île de loisirs a dû
elle aussi se résoudre à fermer son
accès aux piétons aujourd'hui tout comme
les parcs et espaces verts des communes
enfin les services d'accueil des mairies
de l'agglomération sont pour leur grande
majorité totalement fermé au public des
permanences téléphoniques et des
contacts par mail sont encore possibles
pour plus de précisions l idéal est de
consulter les sites internet des
communes